hey guys it is summer here in South
Africa man it is hot I'm just taking a
quick walk outside of the house just to
connect with you guys because our team's
been working really hard these last few
months and I apologize that we couldn't
get the men's lifestyle video to you
yesterday that we are late this week we
tried we couldn't get it on time so
apologies but expect some interesting
things this year we're almost at 1
million and I just want to thank you all
for the support and um just remind you
to live life fully and remember that
this is the day that the Lord has made I
will rejoice and be glad in it check out
this
view thank you so much for all the
support over the last few years please
watch one of these videos here because
you might not have seen them yet I'll
see you there and always remember life
is short so don't waste yours cheers
guys